Jetzt ist Deutschunterricht angesagt.
Bei Erstklässlern wie Frido
ist das Homeschooling besonders schwierig.
Sie müssen ja erst mal die
Grundlagen lernen.
Zusammen mit seiner Mutter lernt Frido
lesen und schreiben – im Wohnzimmer.
Das findet er ...
... eigentlich auch ganz gut.
Am besten find ich es zu viert.
Zu viert, also mit seiner
kleinen Schwester Toni,
der großen Schwester
Selma und ihrer Mutter.
So ist immer was los.
Gestern haben wir auch gespielt,
dass wir die Schulkantine sind.
Da gab’s nämlich Pommes
und dann haben wir so getan ...
haben wir für Toni Fake-Pommes gemacht
aus Weißbrot und haben gespielt,
dass das die drei Schüler der Schule sind.
Ich, also ... wir schaffen fast nie das,
was eigentlich so für einen Tag
vorgesehen wäre.
Und ...
ich wollte halt nie Lehrerin werden.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie man
jemanden dazu bringt,
irgendwie 27-mal hintereinander das F zu
schreiben, wenn er da keinen Bock drauf hat.
Fridos Lehrerinnen Theresa Schmitt und
Anna Vatankhah geben ihr Bestes,
die Kinder und ihre
Eltern digital zu unterstützen –
von ihren privaten Laptops aus.
Mehrmals die Woche gibt es daher
Sprech- und Fragestunden per Video.
Aber Sechsjährigen Schreiben,
Lesen und Rechnen beizubringen,
das ist digital schwierig.
Wir haben manche Kinder, die wir halt
einfach gar nicht erreichen können.
Die ... ja, die lernen jetzt sehr wenig,
aber wir versuchen,
die dann in die Schule zu holen
und hier was mit ihnen zu machen.
Genau. Die, die einfach zu Hause,
ja, nicht lernen können –
aufgrund der Anzahl der Geschwister
und des Raumes und ...
Immerhin die Tablets, die der Berliner Senat
stellt, können jetzt an Kinder verteilt werden,
die keine digitalen Geräte zu Hause haben.
Experten sagen:
Auch das hätte früher kommen müssen.
Die Schulen sind technisch
nicht besser ausgestattet
als im März letzten Jahres.
Die Lehrkräfte haben sich selber
individuell Technik angeschafft,
haben sich schlaugemacht:
Mit welcher Technik funktioniert das gut?
Aber die Bildungsverwaltungen
haben hier ’ne Menge verschlafen.
Aufgrund der hohen Infektionszahlen in Berlin
bleibt diese Schule erst einmal geschlossen.
Zurück bei Mirya Gerardu:
Sie ist gerade in Elternzeit,
ihr Mann arbeitet.
So kriegen sie das mit dem
Homeschooling irgendwie hin.
Also, dass man daneben arbeiten könnte,
ist die absolute Illusion.
Also, wenn ich irgendwas
in die Welt tragen will,
dann ist das, dass es unmöglich ist,
Homeoffice und
Homeschooling zu kombinieren.
Es ist eine Ausnahmesituation,
das wissen die Gerardus.
Sie hoffen trotzdem, dass bald wieder ein
wenig Normalität in ihren Alltag zurückkehrt.